so Lula 83 popularity I go back and I
look at some of the stuff with this guy
to see what he did in the 80s when he's
coming up he's a lathe
operator in a factory okay so what he
was doing uh but he was a uh Community
organizer right became the president of
meta laureges Union uh this was at the
time where they were holding many
strikes you know for the workers and he
was kind of like a uh I don't want to
say Jimmy Hoffa but he was a union uh
name going out there hey it's not fair
this is not enough money we lost strike
let's do this so he kept encouraging
people to strike but then in 1990 when
Fernando color de Melo won this I think
this was his first time losing or second
time he's lost a few times for a bit for
presidency he started Sao Paulo Forum in
Brazil which was officially created by
Fidel Castro and Luis inacio uh with
with him so in a time like this in the
whole outcome was hey organization is
going to bring people together from
political parties and left this
organization from all over Latin America
and the Caribbean where with a very
clear and public plan of Power with what
they want to do anyways so when they
created this at the time in Brazil
how was how did Brazil view Fidel Castro
at this time did the people see him as a
hero did they see him as a man this guy
cares about the poor people and if Lula
is going to be like that or was there
not momentum created yet for Lula it
good point listen in Brazil is very
divided in terms of uh the political
view and all that Fidel Castro is a hero
for a lot of people especially in the
universities
so in the upper classes they love like
this narrative oh a guy that went
against a dictator uh dictatorship
and took power to help people and they
loved that so the education in Cuba uh
the the the social uh Health in Cuba
free healthcare yeah freedom of care
they love this narrative but uh well
nowadays I think they understand uh at
least the majority they understand it
sucks so uh and and just for you to
understand during the many years there's
one there was only one guy that we both
know and and he passed away a few years
ago and he was very important to the
right movement
there was only one guy in the media
talking about this the four of the Sao
Paulo only him and in the mainstream
media they were pretty in it as a
conspiracy theory like no that that
doesn't exist the left is not United to
bring back to Latin America what they
lost in the in Europe so they they
thought it was a lie but yeah many
people still think Fidel Castro is a
kind of hero and uh but with the social
media uh now many many people can
understand better what's going on in
Cuba and all that so there was no it's
important for you guys to understand
there was no right wing movement in
Brazil uh back then and we are talking
about less than a decade ago there was
no right-wing movement there were only
one guy there one another guy there and
that's it is it is it fair to say like
when I read about both of these guys of
politicians in the history of uh Brazil
the two most strongest personalities who
are loud who are you know charismatic
it's these two bolsonaro and Lula is
that a fair assessment where they're
very good at selling their vision and
casting their vision and speaking to
their base and historically there's not
been even JK who's known as your goat
you know he's one of the greatest
presidents you guys have had you know
they they view him as somebody a lot of
people tell me this based on what I'm
reading maybe you may correct me on that
you don't typically hear somebody that
is you know they're more more poised the
way they speak you know hey here's what
we do this is what Brazil is all about
so was that one of the reasons why both
of these guys got the kind of love that
they got I guess so yeah and they were
both both populous but I have a
different different flavors
but to the sense that they appeal to the
common man more than to the to the
establishment but I have to say I've
never seen
anyone like bolsonaro and in the sense
of how much people likes him so with all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
or black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future looks
bright toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]